el médico puede obtener una biopsia de
piel para observar el tejido con un
microscopio y realizar un diagnóstico de
su condición la piel es el órgano más
amplio del cuerpo y es responsable de
regular la temperatura corporal percibir
los estímulos dolorosos y placenteros
proporcionar una barrera protectora
contra bacterias
toxinas
y evitando la evaporación del líquido
interno
la piel consta de tres capas la
epidermis la dermis y la hipodermis la
epidermis ayuda a prevenir que la
mayoría de las bacterias y otras
sustancias extrañas ingresen al cuerpo
la dermis proporciona el soporte a la
epidermis y le otorga a la piel
flexibilidad y dureza la hipodermis es
la capa de células de grasa que
proporciona aislación y apoyo protector
las biopsias de piel se ordenan
comúnmente por verrugas y lunares
cánceres de piel y otros crecimientos
reacciones alérgicas infecciones
bacterianas y micóticas acné psoriasis y
lesiones y cicatrices para todos los
procedimientos de biopsias de piel el
medico inyectará anestesia local en la
piel para adormecer el área
las biopsias por raspado por lo general
se realizan sobre lesiones superficiales
durante este procedimiento
el médico usará un bisturí filoso o una
hoja de afeitar para cortar finamente o
afeitar la capa superior de la lesión
cutánea este tipo de biopsia no requiere
puntos por lo general los médicos
realizan una biopsia por punción para
lesiones cutáneas más profundas
el médico hará girar un bisturí circular
y hueco alrededor de la lesión hasta
cortar completamente a través de la
epidermis y la dermis
él o ella extraerá un cilindro pequeño
de piel por lo general más pequeño que
el tamaño de un sacapuntas que contenga
todas las capas de la piel y la lesión
según el tamaño de la muestra el área
podrá cerrarse con puntos o no
una biopsia excepcional es más grande y
profunda que una biopsia por raspado o
punción se realiza en condiciones como
el cáncer el cual debe ser extraído en
su totalidad el médico llegará tan
profundo como sea necesario para extraer
toda el área visiblemente afectada así
como algún tejido que no esté afectado
que rodee el exterior de la lesión
posteriormente la incisión se cierra con
puntos
después de la biopsia necesitará
mantener el área seca y cubierta con una
venda o gasa estéril durante uno o dos
días
se deberá aplicar una pomada antibiótica
hasta que el área esté completamente
curada se pueda tomar acetaminofén o
ibuprofeno para cualquier dolor que
sienta en la zona de la biopsia